je pense que il ya une grande tendance
qui en transe à dessiner aujourd'hui
donc pas uniquement pour rendre piétonne
certaines certains endroits de la ville
mais pour ré découvrir d'autres manières
de vivre qui peuvent créer donc au cette
altérité et on le voit aujourd'hui comme
un point de rupture qui est je pense
capable de le repenser lié avec ce que
les urbanistes suédois jan guen appelle
donc hors la ville à l'échelle humaine
est ce que les italiens ont appelé el
topo de la chip donc le temps de la
ville est ce que nous nous appellons
donc on avait le dit quart d'heure et
est ce qui a produit des lieux très
agréable à vivre
malgré la densité qui veut que qui ont
peu à voir parce que on a cette espèce
de deux récentes y d'humanité et c'est
que nous voulons aujourd'hui chercher un
sachant que cet urbanisme était
réversible est soulignée d'un cinq
continents qui les narines gâtine
j'allais quitter il ya 40 ans il ya 40
ans il y avait 70 % des requêtes 30%
d'urbain aujourd'hui à 20% de ruraux et
80% durban saleh continuent à le plus
urbanisées au monde
on peut pas y avoir aujourd'hui un
combat pour retrouver la ruralité 10 à
40 ans notre combat aujourd'hui c'est
pour humaniser ses villes pour retrouver
les quartiers pour retrouver donc cette
taupe ophélie pour retrouver l'amour et
l'envi des vivres et pour créer des
contre-pouvoirs locaux dans lesquels on
relocalise 1 crée de l'emploi
il y en a mais une démocratie et qui
peut transformer les choses
on l'a vu encore récemment au chili à
santiago et commença à tourner parce que
il ya eu effectivement il rencontre des
lieux urbains avec son humanité et je
pense qu est ce qu on a perdu et ça on
le retrouve dans la bile et saigne pas
un combat que mène à la campagne
[Musique]